the jurgen experience i think james
cameron nailed something in that avatar
film
that resonates with people in a very
strange way
not just that it was an awesome movie
and it was a [ __ ] awesome movie
but that he he nailed something
that made people want to live like that
you know there was a thing they were
talking about after that movie called
avatar depression
where people were leaving the film
and they were depressed that their life
was
nothing like avatar like pandora
like living like the nod that's it yeah
there was something about
what he nailed he nailed something in
that movie
was like this spiritual connection it
was very ayahuasca-like too this
connection to mother earth and the
nature and and spirits
and the the connection of all of them it
was there's something about that film
he he hit some nerve with people i've
never heard of another film
generating depression that you know
there's no star wars depression
at least when you see some of the ones
that
have recently come out yeah that's
depressing well that's what happens when
the executives get a hold of it and they
go hey you got to go to cuba
and grab the people and put them in the
boat that's right and then they listen
that's right
that's exactly right that's exactly what
happened but you know james cameron's
such a force of nature
you can't really do that to him he
figured something out in those movies
he figured out how to tap into some sort
of elemental
area of the psyche that people it just
resonated with people
like sort of the same way i think you
know people that talk about
um folks that live like a subsistence
life
you know people that have gone to the
woods and they they just live off the
land
they talk about this like deep
connection to nature that they get from
that
and how it makes them feel fulfilled
they don't feel depressed
they feel very engaged and you know
there's a guy named um
jaimo he lives in the arctic and vice
did this whole series on him called the
hindmos arctic adventure
and uh one of the things that he was
saying is he came out there like in the
1970s to work for the forestry
department and just lived there for the
rest of his life
he's up there right now with his family
like he's married to this indigenous
woman and
they live off the land he eats caribou
and fish and his whole life is like
hunting and gathering
but he's like this is how people are
supposed to and he's a very intelligent
man very articulate
so when you hear him talk he's not some
weirdo that lives in the woods
he's a guy who recognizes like there's
something about this that resonates with
humans
this life this like the being you're
you're you're connected in the way that
you're supposed to be
and he thinks that what we've done by
creating cities and electricity and
electronics and you know social media
and all the [ __ ] that we deal with
today that we've disconnected ourselves
from the things that
that really make us human and that i
believe
his his life is more connected to it but
there's even
a deeper connection and that's how the
na'vi lived
and you know if you read about there's
there's many stories about native
americans
where they would especially the comanche
would kidnap um
people they would kidnap like young
children oh that's a great book
which one under the harvest moon oh okay
yeah
do yourself a favor uh well well empire
the summer moon which one that i'm
talking about that's the one story oh
okay yeah same one yeah about yeah
cynthia anne parker
yeah there's a photo of her out there in
the lobby that's who that is that's
cynthia i knew i knew
from someone yeah yeah that's quanah
parker that's her son
that guy over there on the one that's
made out of bullet shots that's one of
my favorite books ever it's [ __ ]
amazing
amazing it's amazing and that's one of
the things they said was that she did
not want to go back to western
civilization she's like
you guys live like idiots like this is a
[ __ ] way to live
there's something about that movie that
tapped into
that but also tapped into this like
spiritual realm that exists in
psychedelics
cameron [ __ ] nailed it man he nailed
a lot of people like have you ever had
him on
no no he's he's the great first of all
he's the most humble
i've never worked with him but my dear
dear dear dear
friend who passed away a few years ago
bill paxton i love that guy
he's the best he's one of my best he was
one of my best friends and he's
he and jim were in roger corman's
uh production mill together they were
both like standby painters
so he's been in every jim cameron movie
ever ever made and
he introduced me to jim and um uh
there was a minute where i was going to
play the billy zane part in titanic
and um the uh jim is
he's like there's no one like him
there's literally nobody like him
the [ __ ] guy went to the bottom of
the ocean so bill and he went
to these bills like goddamn jim's taking
me down to the titanic
i'm going next thursday and
and they went down to the titanic they
had lunch on the deck of the [ __ ]
titanic
what yeah oh my god and then bill came
up and everybody was like
ashen-faced and freaking out and 9 11
had happened
bill paxton was on the deck of the
titanic when 9 11 happened holy
jim cameron is that crazy oh my god
that's insane insane that's insane